nicolas compagnons et amis nous sommes
les héritiers d'une histoire immense et
chacun sait qu'il fallut bien des héros
et des bâtisseurs pour nous donner le
privilège de dire cette phrase belle et
simple je suis français aux jeunes
républicains est toujours populaire
je dis qu'il n'ya pas de bonheur sans
conquête pour se hisser au rang des
nations développées la france a
travaillé dur et les français eurent le
courage de revendiquer un destin il
fallut et il faudra encore produire
inventer créer des richesses pour rester
une flamme dans le monde
la france que nous aimons charles c'est
la france des marins de l'île de sein
qui choisir la liberté et l'honneur ces
deux valeurs ont toujours 20 ans une
fois les armes posé il réconcilièrent
l'europe
nous devons être fidèles à leur sagesse
notre france assume le combat pour la
dignité de l'homme
autrefois pour l'universalité de ses
droits aujourd'hui contre le drapeau
noir le drapeau noir de ceux qui égorge
des chrétiens qui abattent des
caricaturistes qui martyrisent les
femmes et les hommes
notre credo c'est la liberté la liberté
pour vivre debout c'est la patrie pour
rassembler
et c'est l'europe pour civilisation les
temps changent mais notre ambition reste
intacte il s'agit de hisser la nation
vers le meilleur d'elle-même
les obstacles sont innombrables mais la
france possède toutes les qualités pour
se reprendre et pour surprendre le monde
rappelons-nous la nuit du 4 août 1789
l'alliance des monarchies européennes
assistent pétrifiés à l'abolition des
privilèges
ce jour là l'assemblée avait choisi de
tout abattre pour tout reconstruire en
1958 la france est en faillite et se
demande comment boucler ses fins de mois
dès les premiers jours le général de
gaulle prend parti pour la modernisation
sans laquelle et ce sont ces mots nous
resterons un pays à la traîne
le reste est connu c'est la réforme
c'est l'expansion et ce sont les trente
glorieuses et bien mes amis ces tranches
d'histoire prouve que tout est possible
à une france décidée et à une france
rénovée
l'histoire
l'histoire n'est pas finie la france
peut-être en moins de dix ans la
première puissance européenne
ça n'est pas un rêve c'est le défi que
nous allons relever
nous avons tellement d'atouts pour cela
la démographie la technologie la science
la culture la productivité l' influence
diplomatique et militaire
non le génie français n'est pas mort
c'est notre système qui est usée et un
système ça se change
on les dit on les dit découragé abattu
blasé mais ils sont des millions ces
français dévoué et ingénieux prêts à se
retrousser les manches
je ne voit dans leurs yeux ni lâcheté ni
résignation mais bien une force une
force qui attend son heure
cette force mes amis elle peut être
extraordinaire
si nous savons la guider vers des
changements inédit jamais je n'ai senti
autant de lucidité et d'exaspération
face au blocage
mais cette force elle peut être aussi
destructrice
si nous nous contentons d'exercer le
pouvoir comme une fin en soi
trop de promesses déçues
trop de souffrance sociale la politique
est en état d'urgence
le chômage s'étant les milliards de
dettes nous étouffe la tentation
communautariste et les votes extremis
gangrène notre société
le parti des désespérés et celui des
abstentionnistes sont les premiers de
france et au delà de nos frontières pas
de répit c'est l'europe
tiraillé entre la faillite
grecque et le divorce britannique c'est
la fronde des syriza dépôt nemos des
nationalistes écossais et des autres
partis radicaux qui bouscule les vieux
échiquier tandis qu'en méditerranée
ce sont des flottes de réfugiés qui font
route vers nous
fuyant le chaos et la menace djihadiste
le monde est en surchauffe et notre
démocratie est en dépression
voilà les circonstances qui entourent
notre congrès qui ne peut pas être un
ripolinage du passé mais qui doit être
un nouveau départ
nous avons décidé de nous intitulé les
républicains ce choix nous oblige plus
que tout autre
parce que lorsque l'on prend la
république comme étendard
alors il ne nous est pas permis de
décevoir
et puis ce que l'exemple doit venir de
nous mêmes
faisons de la liberté de l'égalité et de
la fraternité la devise vivante des
républicains la liberté la liberté
permet de repousser tous qui nivelle
tout ce qui uniformise tout ce qui est
en régie menthe
elle est l'oxygène dont la france a
besoin chez nous
républicains tous les débats sont
ouverts toutes les compétitions sont
possibles dès lors que le respect
prévost
comment pourrions nous inviter les
français à aimer davantage la liberté
si nous ne sommes pas le mouvement où
chacun peut aller au bout de ses mérites
et de ses convictions
l'égalité l'égalité promise à tous les
français non seulement pour avoir des
droits équivalents mais avec
l'obligation de répondre à leurs devoirs
l'état ne peut pas tout et il faut
refonder la société républicaine en
commençant par le début
c'est à dire par l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire par l'esprit citoyen
soyons sont citoyens et digne de leur
devoir
ceux qui se lèvent et qui s'interpose
lorsque quelqu'un est agressée dans le
métro le saut aussi ses parents qui
avant de tout exiger de l'école
transmettent à leurs enfants les valeurs
de l'autorité la culture et le civisme
qui doivent nous rassembler son sont
dignes de leurs devoirs ceux qui font
leurs heures supplémentaires
ceux qui n'attendent pas le dernier mois
de leur allocation pour chercher un
emploi
ce qui n'empêche pas leurs parachutes
dorés lorsque leur bilan ne le mérite
pas
comment comment demander aux français
d'être vigilants sur leurs devoirs
si nous les républicains n'exigeons pas
plus de nous mêmes
sincère honnête dévoué à la france
nous devront l'être plus que jamais et
la fraternité la fraternité celle
oubliés de notre devise
elle est pourtant le fil qui relie tous
les coeurs dans nos écoles le récit
national est tout juste chuchoter alors
que la fierté collective est la source
de notre union dans nos cités les voyous
et les intégristes veulent fixer les
règles
la confiance mutuelle devient la peur
réciproque
on ne se parle plus on se juge aux
apparences et les écouteurs sur les
oreilles
certains n'entendent plus l'enfant
thiery dans la rue est ce ainsi que les
hommes vivent
non les français ont le coeur serré mais
les français sont généreux
il milite par milliers dans des
associations
il n'oublie jamais de participer aux
actions humanitaires
il n'hésite pas à travailler le dimanche
si cela est nécessaire
et bien la politique c'est l'art d'unir
toutes les bonnes volontés
c'est l'art de réveiller en chaque être
humain cette part de lumière qui ne
demande qu'à briller la lutte des
classes n'est pas républicaine
la lutte des races ou celle des
religions ne sont pas républicaine
je n'ai
je n'ai jamais accepter l'idée qu'il y
est un peuple de gauche
dresser contre un peuple de droite ce ne
sont pas dans les simplifications
idéologique ou dans le trait des
caricatures que ce incarnent l'intérêt
général
rassemblés s'il est bien un objectif qui
doit être le nôtre c'est celui ci
puisque la république que nous prenons
en main doit être partout à tous jeunes
ou vieux hommes et femmes fortunées
modeste nous devons donner le goût
d'être ensemble d'agir ensemble
si les républicains n'étaient qu'une
machine électorale une caserne où les
adhérents viendrait chercher les ordres
si nous n'étions pas cette famille où le
débat fraternel et à chaque étage
si nous n'étions que conflit et
invectives à l'égard de ceux qui pensent
ou qui agissent autrement si nous
n'étions pas les interprètes de toutes
les sensibilités française alors la
république ne saurait pas en nous
certains pensent que l'on convaincra les
français en prenant tous les virages en
serrant vers la droite
d'autres en conduisant au milieu de la
route sans parler des démagogues qui
disent qu'on peut lâcher le volant et
regarder derrière soi
et bien moi je ne veux pas découper la
france en tranches
je la prends comme un bloc avec amour
avec la conviction qu'il faut se
réinventer ensemble pour espérer pour
proposer et pour agir
les municipales les départementales et
bientôt les élections régionales nous
regagnons du terrain bravo à nos
candidats
bravo à nos militants mais gare au
vertige
n'ayant pas le réflexe de penser que le
balancier électorale jours a
mécaniquement notre faveur pariez sur le
pendule miser sur le rejet de la gauche
non nous n'avons pas le droit d'être
aussi peu ambitieux à lire les sondages
tout le monde semble capable de renvoyer
françois hollande à sa normalité mais la
question centrale à laquelle il nous
faut répondre c'est pour quoi faire et
comment il faut le faire
c'est si l'alternance n'est qu'une
alternance parmi tant d'autres cela ne
servira à rien la france s'enfonce rats
et la colère gronde en est elle
explosera un jour parce que nous aurons
par faiblesse par commodité électorale
laisser déposséder le pays de ceux qu'il
tient pour sacrer la souveraineté
nationale il n'y a pas de souveraineté
sans puissance
si le pays s'appauvrit si le peuple doit
s'en remettre à bruxelles pour connaître
son sort s'il devait être l'otage du
fonds monétaire alors à quoi bon la
démocratie nous avons un défi et ce défi
c'est de battre la gauche et l'extrême
droite non par défaut mais par adhésion
des français un projet précis puissant
appuyé sur un mode d'exécution sans
faille
mes amis la république est une révolte
elle est révolutionnaire
là où les bastilles doivent tomber et
elles doivent tomber
elles doivent tomber là où la rigidité
du code du travail
exclu ce qu'ils cherchent un travail
elle doit tomber
là où l'excès de fiscalité décourage les
talents là où la barrière des
réglementations bloc l'innovation là où
l'opium des déficits nous endort là où
le nivellement par le bas
noah le mérite de ceux qui n'ont dans
leur main que leur audace on m'accuse
parfois d'avoir le langage du sang et
des larmes mais mes amis le sang et les
larmes
c'est aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui pour
6 millions de français sans emploi
c'est aujourd'hui le sang et les larmes
pour les deux millions de jeunes qui ne
sont ni à l'école ni en formation ni
dans l'emploi le sang et les larmes
c'est aujourd'hui pour les travailleurs
pauvres le sang et les larmes c'est
aujourd'hui pour les artisans et les
agriculteurs qui ne peuvent plus verser
un euro de salaire à la fin du mois le
sang et les larmes
c'est aujourd'hui pour ces retraités qui
ne font qu'un repas par jour oui contre
le sang et les larmes je choisis la
vérité je choisi l'action et je choisis
la liberté contre les conservatismes qui
nous étouffe
oui la liberté et le meilleur logiciel
pour déclencher le progrès économique
technologique et sociale et puis il y à
l'unité nationale 65 millions de
français dans un monde de 7 milliards
d'êtres humains plutôt que de dire et
moi et moi et moi nous devons dire nous
parce que la france n'est pas un puzzle
parce que la france n'est pas une
juxtaposition de clan de ghettos de
communautés affichant leurs règles au
dessus des règles de la république
nous sommes une nation de citoyens ou
transcendant les origines et les
croyances seul doit compter l'amour du
pays et le respect de la loi partout où
l'autorité de l'état est bafouée les
républicains sont là partout où la
laïcité et défié les républicains seront
là partout où l'identité de la france et
des racines et les républicains seront
là pas de compromis pas de compromis
avec le racisme
pas de compromis avec l'antisémitisme
pas de compromis avec la haine de la
france face à eux nous serons
implacables
mon plus jeune fils
à 13 ans je le regarde et je regarde la
france
je veux qu'ils grandissent dans un pays
où le dépassement de choix est encore
possible ou le goût de la liberté est
plus fort que la peur de l'échec ou la
justice serait rendue aux être courageux
et bon je veux qu'ils soient fiers
d'être français et je veux qu'ils soient
fiers d'être en même temps citoyens
d'une robe brillante et protectrice pour
cet avenir pour cet avenir que je
voudrais lui promettre il va falloir mes
amis combattre il va falloir bâtir
il va falloir rassembler en amour il va
falloir être des républicains